you really were blue coke weren't you i
wasn't blocker yeah at the place you
showed which was next door to heisham
nuclear power station
the thing is i got settler because i was
i worked at a really good one in
yarmouth great yarmouth got sacked which
is another story and then uh was sacked
and then and was sent to we'll move on
to that in a minute but uh
you sent it this way sent to that one as
a sort of punishment it was like a you
you're going to morkum
to do six months because you have just
you've just done something what had you
done
well
something that was considered cheeky in
the 70s but now is illegal
it was actually an incident where it was
my first attempt to stand stan comedy
and what happened was i i'd always
wanted to do stand-up comedy i didn't
have the guts to do it i got very drunk
i had a go at doing it as a blue coat my
mate said to me just copy all the other
comedians at pontins and steal their
jokes and basically talk to the front
row so you're supposed to say where are
you from they say scotland do you say
who paid for your holiday where you from
wales you make a noise like a sheep
rubbish jokes
but i said that's terrible he said don't
worry you're just padding what you're
doing is you're looking for comedy gold
which is where you're from they say kent
and you say what did you call me right
now at pontons this used to take the
roof off right
so i tried it
but i was very drunk
so i go on stage
and i say where are you from
this bloke says scotland
i can't remember the joke
i say hello
then i said to the where you from the
guy says wales
i black out and i go hi
i panic
and then i say
anyone in from kent
and this bloke shouts out me
and i said
well you're
[Applause]
so i'm
[Music]
[Applause]